[Musica]
un coniglio che cosa ci fai qua
forse ho capito sei venuto qua per
portarmi altre uova di pasqua vero è
visto merlino è venuto qua per portarci
altro uovo di pasqua sei contento ma
quella massa per che cosa serve cioè nel
senso non serve a niente vero e poi dove
sono le uno di pasqua dove limes
non c'è nessuno di pasqua riesce a
scappare dovessero trovare dati venire
riempie
i ragazzi
bentornati sonorizzazioni stima
challenge a grandissima richiesta visto
che avete lasciato tantissimi likes
tantissimi in piace sullo scorso video
in cui dovevo trovare le uovo di pasqua
con coniglio malefico
ora il coniglio è tornato e dovrò
trovare tutti gli ingredienti slime
nascosti dal coniglio cattivo e devo
riuscire a completare e fare lo stage
per vincere questa challenge altrimenti
avrà vinto lui ovviamente lasciate un
bel mi piace anche su questo video se
volete altre sale già trova gli
ingredienti slime consiglio se ci purché
altri personaggi volete vedere e mi
raccomando se non mi seguite ancora
stilizzate mandati a seguirmi in nome è
anita stories
siete pronti avete già preso i pop corn
iniziamo subito questa challenge assieme
marino mi il 3 in questa challenge può
stare dalla parte del cattivo deriva sta
solo pensando street ieri il suo secchi
novità ghetto di superman che ci arriva
vuoi dirmi qualcosa perché guardando qua
c'è qualcosa con la forse merlino vostre
magica uno stile per menti grazie
se non sei bravissimo ma non sapete che
questo è davvero magica guardate magica
scelgo te non ha funzionato aspetta
magica crude ma in genere funziona
magica scelgo te ecco vedete si muove
[Musica]
però in genere si muove usa l'ha seguita
splash abbiamo trovato la soluzione per
lenti grazie al berlino grazie merlino
mi raccomando continua ad aiutarmi e di
figure dove sono gli altri ingredienti
come ho fatto a non vederlo prima questa
certezza sta andando benissimo ho già
preso due sono ancora in gioco i voti
ricche o più di una vita
il coniglio mi ha preso avete visto era
lì sulla porta che mi osservava tutto il
tempo almeno vuol dire che io piedi una
vita anche se non so quanti video forse
no 33 giorni tre vite ce la farò beh
almeno gli ingredienti sono qua
controlliamo qua nella stanza non mi
sembra difendere il coniglio da nessuna
parte
dobbiamo stare attenti visto che solo
due vite controlliamo nel nostro solito
posto fortunato e cioè dove ci sono i
pupazzi
ragazze sta controllando ma non trovo
proprio niente ei pappagalli liu perché
lo meglio di tu a trovare gli
ingredienti 3 visto che mi arrivano mi
aiuta tanto basta va bene c'è qualcosa
là dietro il cuscino evviva
l'ho trovata quasi subito bene ragazzi
allora abbiamo già trovato la foto ci
mancano pochissime cose anche se non so
se forse è meglio uscire da questa
stanzetta perché qua abbiamo già trovato
una cosa e nell'altra stanza abbiamo
trovato due cose quindi sicuramente sarà
me che strano comunque stavo dicendo
sarà meglio cambiare stanza perché
sicuramente non aspetta aspetta
parliamo ok se mi dici dove un altro
ingrediente ti do un altissimo e carote
però il problema è solo che non ce le ho
qua c'è nel senso non c'è l'acqua ma
devo andare a prenderli e mi lasci il
tempo di andare a prenderle magari posso
prendere dichiara che se ho visto il
potere a prenderle che posso prendermi
che ne pensi
no no ho perso ma altra finito il
coniglio l'anno scorso qua dentro
nell'armadio magari nascosto da qualche
parte positiva e che ora abbiamo tre
cose ne mancano solo due
ovviamente la colla sarà come sempre la
più difficile passiamo a seguirlo nel
rino regioni sovrano e la paletta
se stai guardando invece la sopra c'è
qualcosa da sopra
bravissimo c'era un po di gioco stupro
grazie per lì nel mio alleato vedere se
ho fatto grazie ai proventi mentre
manette grazie no no non si mangia per
me non si mangia lo ha subito ammetterlo
è ora un cassone la colla forse possiamo
farcela ragazzi grazie mille berlino beh
ora non è che ti dispiacerebbe dirmi
dove anche la corda magari così
riusciamo a vincere la challenge vediamo
dobbiamo seguirlo e sotto al letto
merlino stimi sia sotto il letto
non c'è niente
ok siamo qua
adesso qualcosa
incontro
[Applauso]
venuta un'idea siccome con il suo sta
nascondendo la colla nel taschino e
quindi sarà molto difficile prenderla
senza perdere la mia ultima vita
la mia idea è di prendere delle carote
politico cosa ora andiamo a prendere le
carote
che il coniglio non appaia quali
improvviso o almeno speriamo che non
abbia già mangiato tutte le carote
spero che ne sia rimasta almeno una
perché per il mio piano ne basta una
e fortuna l'ha trovata eccola qua
abbiamo la carota e poi un'altra cosa
ora vi spiego che cos'è che siamo
tornati in camera
ora vi spiego il mio piano io metterò
una carota sul letto sul letto o non lo
so da quale parte forse sì sul letto e
poi metto delle gocce di questo questo è
del sonnifero
così spero che lui cascherà nella
trappola mancera la carota si
addormenterà e una volta che si
addormenta posso prendere la colla fare
lo slime farlo sparire perché funzioni
questo piano incrociate le dita per me
ora andiamo a mettere il sonnifero e ho
messo tantissimo non si spegnerà più
ecco fatto carriera nella mia trappola
spero proprio di sì questa è la carota
con il sonnifero che potrei metterla non
so se metterla nel letto
forse lui se ne accorse lamento per
terra sì non penserà che una trappola
forse pensa che mi è caduta ok ora come
faccio a farlo arrivare lo chiamo frutto
di lea
io mi nascondo la sopra poi chiamerò il
coniglio così non sarà in grado di
prendermi e non sprecherò la mia ultima
vita inizia a salire quando ecco qua
siamo in mezzo ai pupazzi ora chiamo al
coniglio ma noi dobbiamo nasconderci
signor con il signor coniglio vieni o
qualcosa per te
che veda la carota
mi sta a guardare
7 minuto ecco la vista
buongiorno 41 ne sei accorto signori
alterata mangiante per questo mi sono
funzioni l'ha mangiata tutta si
addormenterà forse non funziona
sonnifero sui conigli giganti cattivi
[Musica]
non capisco a rossano si è addormentato
se fosse solo una vita ma si vede che
sta dormendo
l'annunciata ora scendiamo e andiamo
rubargli la colla dal taschino
penso che così non svegliarlo
ragazzi passate pronto ora proviamo far
sparire il coniglio non so se funzionerà
ok vediamo se funziona
ma non funziona se speziato fede mi sono
svegliato ma tanto non riuscirei al
vizio nella saarland e fai da te perché
la collasserà proprio a te che non è una
donna forse stai cercando questa tesi da
no mi dispiace ma in realtà angelo slang
prontocasa la riuscirai a picco è la
sala perché ora che credeva portare a di
te ti sbagli perché guarda un po allo
stremo pronto fisco dice scomparso
abbiamo vinto anche questo challenge mi
raccomando lasciate un mi piace se
volete vedere tornare il coniglio a 30
mila mi piace tornerà anche il coniglio
e ora vi lascio qua 4 caso il linee su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
pura visione
ciao
[Musica]